the brain is the most complex organ in
the human body as part of the nervous
system the brain coordinates all of the
body's functions in adult humans the
brain is a three pound gelatinous mass
of fat and protein it's comprised of
four main regions the cerebrum the
cerebellum the brain stem and the
diencephalon and each one controls
specific tasks the largest section is
the cerebrum and it makes up over
three-quarters of the brain's volume it
consists of neurons and nerve fibers
that transmit information from the
neurons throughout the brain and body
the cerebrum controls higher functions
such as learning reasoning and speech
plus senses like sight and hearing under
the cerebrum is the second largest part
of the brain the cerebellum much like
the cerebrum the cerebellum has nerve
cells and nerve fibers it carries
signals to other parts of the brain and
the spinal cord
the cerebellum is responsible for
coordinating muscle movements
particularly those that help maintain
the body's balance and posture the third
region the brainstem lies in front of
the cerebellum and anchors the brain
into the spinal cord the brainstem is
the collection of structures that
include the pons a mass of nerve fibers
that carry sensory information the
midbrain a region of fibers and
structures that help control movement
along with auditory and visual
processing and the medulla oblongata
which creates motor and sensory pathways
between the midbrain the pons and the
spinal cord altogether the parts of the
brainstem controlled vital bodily
functions such as cardiac activity
respiration digestion and sleep
the fourth region is located above the
brainstem and makes up the core of the
brain the diencephalon about the size of
an apricot the diencephalon is a
grouping of several structures the
thalamus which processes and transmits
information from all senses except smell
and the hypothalamus and pituitary gland
which work together to produce and
regulate neuro chemicals these
structures help govern sensations weight
regulation energy and instinctual
behaviors such as eating drinking and
having sex the brains four main
components the diencephalon brainstem
cerebellum and cerebrum work in sync to
ensure bodily functions are fully
operational the brain has even evolved
mechanisms to protect itself one such
mechanism is the blood-brain barrier a
semipermeable cellular wall that only
allows specific chemicals to enter from
the body's bloodstream into the brain
[Music]
despite this protection tumors and other
complications can lead to
life-threatening problems and diseases
in the brain such as dementia thankfully
scientists have found ways to improve
brain health staying physically active
and eating a balanced diet may preserve
cognitive function and even reduce the
risk of developing Alzheimer's so while
the brain only makes up a small
percentage of the body it plays a
crucial role in the body's functions and
overall well-being
you
you
[Music]
you